good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight there was a horrifying
we're sad to tell you a horrifying
amount of violence in the United States
over the weekend as increasingly there
is over just two days at least 104
Americans were shot to death in major
American cities that's a lot how many
well for perspective on the single
deadliest day of the Iraq war that would
be January of 2005 a total of 37
Americans died
so what's happening in our cities right
now looks a lot like a war even if we
rarely acknowledge it Dallas Milwaukee
Los Angeles Philadelphia many other
Metro areas recorded murders over the
weekend that's typical now in St Louis
13 people were shot five of them fatally
in Chicago 33 were gunned down five of
those died
in Laguna Woods California Chinese
immigrant from Las Vegas walked into a
Presbyterian church and shot six elderly
Taiwanese parishioners police say he was
motivated by some kind of political and
ethnic hatred
and of course most famously of all on
Saturday afternoon a teenager in a mock
military uniform walked into a grocery
store in Buffalo and shot more than a
dozen strangers with a rifle no doubt
you've seen accounts of this on the news
which you probably haven't seen are
details about any of the 10 Americans
who were murdered in that store in
Buffalo you may not even know their
names much less who they were or who
they loved most of them were black we
know that but beyond the way they look
not a lot has been reported about them
because the coverage hasn't been about
them
nor in fact has it really been about the
gunman he was an 18 year old called
Peyton Gendron Gendron was mentally ill
everyone around him knew that including
his teachers and the local police less
than a year ago Gendron was committed to
a mental hospital after threatening to
murder his classmates at a school
graduation ceremony
so on Saturday after he made good on his
long-standing threat to open fire into a
crowd Gendron left in 180-page letter
that he said would explain his motives
you probably heard this document
described as a racist Manifesto but
that's not quite right
it's definitely racist bitterly so
Gendron reduces people to their skin
color that's the essence of racism and
it's immoral
but what he wrote does not add up to a
Manifesto it is not a blueprint for a
new extremist political movement much
less the potential inspiration for a
racist Revolution anyone who claims that
it is is lying or hasn't read it instead
gendron's letter is a rambling Pastiche
of slogans and internet memes some of
which flatly contradict one another the
document is not recognizably left-wing
or right-wing it's not really political
at all the document is crazy it's the
product of a diseased and organized mind
at one point gender suggests that Fox
News is part of some Global conspiracy
against him
he writes like the mental patient he is
disjointed irrational paranoid
now that's true not that it makes the
atrocities he committed easier to bear
if your daughter was murdered on
Saturday in Buffalo you wouldn't care
why the killer did it or who he voted
for
but the truth about Peyton Gendron does
tell you a lot about the ruthlessness
and dishonesty of our political
leadership
within minutes of Saturday's shooting
before all of the bodies of those 10
murdered Americans had even been
identified by their loved ones
professional Democrats had begun a
coordinated campaign to blame those
murders on their political opponents
they did it they said immediately Patron
Gendron was the heir to Donald Trump
they told us trumpism committed mass
murder in Buffalo
and for that reason it followed
logically we must suspend the First
Amendment that's hardly an exaggeration
of what they're saying here's a
selection from yesterday's Sunday shows
uh social media companies and law
enforcement
uh have not done enough
uh to monitor to ban to restrict and to
limit hate speech
on their sites hate speech is not
freedom of speech as you know the First
Amendment does not protect hate speech
I'll protect the First Amendment any day
of the week but you don't protect hate
speech you don't protect incendiary
speech you're not allowed to scream fire
in a crowded theater there are
limitations on speech and right now we
have seen this run rampant
so what is hate speech well it's speech
that our leaders hate so because of
mentally ill teenage or murdered
strangers you cannot be allowed to
express your political views out loud
that's what they're telling you that's
what they've wanted to tell you for a
long time but Saturday's Massacre gives
them a pre-text justification
you have to ask yourself who behaves
like that what sort of person uses mass
murder as an excuse to give a campaign
speech or seize more political power
we'll find out tomorrow when Joe Biden
travels to the scene of this atrocity in
Buffalo to speak to the country we
haven't seen an advanced copy of his
remarks but we can guess what we will
hear
Biden's approval rating appears to be
the lowest ever recorded for a president
the century lower than Donald Trump's
that is a disaster for his party the
Democratic party will suffer for this in
this Fall's elections Biden still has
time to change course and fix it he
could try to improve the lives of Voters
who are dissatisfied with him that is
entirely possible that's what
politicians typically do when they're
down they listen to the people who might
re-elect them but Biden doesn't plan to
do that and we know for a fact because
politicoat has reported it instead Biden
has decided to attack people who
disapprove according to political quote
Biden has taken to telling his aides
that he no longer recognizes the GOP
which he now views as an existential
threat to the nation's democracy
end quote
people who disagree with Joe Biden
according to Joe Biden are now a quote
existential threat to the nation like Al
Qaeda or climate change a threat that by
definition is so profound we must
declare war upon it if we're to survive
now keep in mind this threat that Biden
is referring to is you
he's talking about his fellow Americans
no president has ever spoken like this
ever Joe Biden does it regularly and
he's certain to do it again tomorrow
but most painful and destructive at all
Biden is likely to use racial wounds in
order to make his point
there is no Behavior worse than this
all race politics is bad no matter what
flavor those politics happen to be no
race politics is better than any other
all of it is poison race Politics
subsumes the individual into the group
it erases people it dehumanizes them
race politics elevates appearance over
initiative and decency and all the other
god-given qualities that makes every
person of every color unique yet morally
equal to every other person
and above all race politics always makes
us hate each other and always in a very
predictable way
so let's say you were to make identity
politics mandatory in your country as
they have how could you be surprised
when that leads as it inevitably will to
White identity politics well you could
not be surprised you did it and it was
always going to happen
and then what happens next nothing good
race politics is a sin race politics
always leads to violence and death they
learned that lesson in Rwanda in 1994.
identity politics ended in genocide in
Rwanda that killed 800 000 people
in response to those Horrors the
rwandans did something that we might
learn from they moved in the opposite
direction from the one that Joe Biden is
currently taking the United States quote
ethnicity has already been stripped out
of school books and rubbed off
government identity cards reported the
New York Times government documents no
longer mention Hutu or Tutsi and the
country's newspapers and radio stations
steer clear of the labels as well most
dramatic is how rwanda's 8 million
people now shun the identifications the
racial identifications that seem to loom
so large 10 years ago as Hutu extremists
began their mass killings end quote
they have de-emphasized race in Rwanda
intentionally and systematically Rwandan
citizens are Citizens First members of
racial or tribal groups second or not at
all result there have been no more
genocides in Rwanda and that could
easily be the path forward for this
country too there was only one answer to
Rising racial tension and that's to
de-escalate and do what we have done and
tried to do for hundreds of years which
is work toward colorblind meritocracy
and treat people as human beings created
by God rather than as faceless members
of interest groups that might benefit
some political party or or other we have
a moral duty to do this because all
people have equal moral value no matter
what they look like all lives matter
period
that's not the determination of the US
government that's the determination of
God and it's true and most Americans
already believe it they would like to
see a return to the American way of life
and the American way of life is
meritocracy judgment by what I do not by
how I look by the content of my
character not the color of my skin we
have a monument on the mall to this
and yet suddenly every voice in power is
leading us in the opposite direction and
what's the Terminus of that Journey it's
destruction
everybody knows this only our leaders
stand in the way of fixing a problem
that is growing worse by the day
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight